america is a frustrating place i know it
you know it
life right now is hard and when it gets
this hard sometimes you need someone to
talk to
someone smart someone funny someone who
won't judge you if you eat totino's
pizza rolls for every meal
you need a fun auntie
oh look at you now we don't have a lot
of time but first things first
you look good shoot you look just like
me when i was your
age gosh we're cute anyway
i know you're having a rough time right
now because all your little friends are
pressuring you to break quarantine
but let me tell you something those are
not your real friends
and if you tell me who's bothering you i
will friend them on facebook and cuss
them out in the comments
shoot all right you know what it's cold
in here but
i refuse to wear a jacket sleeves make
me feel trapped speaking of traps
do you feel trapped at your job if you
do you better tell me
because i will venmo you some money
right now oh
speaking of money look here i found this
scratch-off
on the train and i won 20 dollars now
don't tell anyone i gave that to you i'm
not a bank
this condo doesn't pay for itself and my
playboy money ran out in the 90s
it is chilly
anyway some family gossip now just
between you and me
jason isn't our biological cousin he's a
play cousin
but don't tell anyone or treat him any
different oh
my lover is here i always make him ring
the doorbell even though he lives here
this is my condo okay all right i love
you
and remember wap is a beautiful song and
if anyone tries to tell you
otherwise tell them that if god didn't
want us to have wap he wouldn't have
made judge jo brown so damn fine
and that's in the bible because
i'm coming i guess
oh my glasses are right here
all right i'll see you next time you're
my favorite
don't tell anyone
[Music]
you